die Arbeit muss gemacht werden aber wie
und wann das wird immer mehr zum Thema
zwei Millionen offene Jobs in
Deutschland da müssen bessere
Arbeitsbedingungen her wie viele
Urlaubstage möchte man nehmen ist
komplett frei nach oben hin kann jeder
machen wie viele möchte durch die
Spätschicht haben wir es geschafft dass
wir mehr junge Leute für den Beruf
begeistern können wir haben einen
Dienstplan der ist Blanco da ist nichts
drauf und wir schreiben den komplett
selber mehr Eigenverantwortung mehr
Flexibilität für die Mitarbeiter sonst
sind sie weg
für mich ist es eine große Erleichterung
um 5 Uhr anzufangen weil ich meinen Tag
so besser planen und nutzen kann und
heute stelle ich natürlich meine Wünsche
da steht keine Nachricht drinne und zu
bekommen ich auch keine Nachtschicht
ganz ohne Nachtarbeit geht's aber wieder
bei der Bahn noch beim Bäcker 3 Uhr früh
und hier raucht schon der Ofen
Hochbetrieb in der Backstube der
Münchner Bäckerei brücklmeier
Bäckergeselle galligalliano fängt um 22
Uhr an und arbeitet die Nacht durch mich
persönlich macht
Spaß weil es hat Vorteil dass sie für
meine Familie mehr da bin weil Nacht
schlafen sowieso alle und dann habe ich
ja tagsüber ein bisschen mehr Zeit für
meine Familie und kann auch ein bisschen
für mich die Zeit genießen
Schwimmbad gehen im Sommer weil viele
aber lieber tagsüber arbeiten hat Julia
Chef Sebastian brücklmeier eine
Spätschicht eingeführt die beginnt erst
um 5 Uhr früh statt um drei
möglich wurde das weil der Brotteig
durch neue enzymärmere Mehlsorten länger
reifen kann diese Leibe wurden schon
gestern hergerichtet und müssen jetzt
nur noch in den Ofen geschoben werden
ja das Brot hilft uns weil wir ganz
einfach dadurch weniger Leute in der
Früh brauchen das wurde vorbereitet und
wir können das jetzt einfach aus der
Kühlung rausholen und dann backen und
dann müssen weniger in der nachtaktiv
sein denn nicht alle mögen die nach
dabei und es gibt noch einen Vorteil
wenn der Teig mehr Zeit zum Reifen hat
wird das Brot bekömmlicher ich bin super
ich mag nicht so hell gebackene Brot ist
darf ruhig äh eine dunkle Kruste haben
von dem her mir gefällt sehr sehr gut
und Volumen ist auch sehr schön geworden
um 5 Uhr früh sind die meisten Brote
gebacken die Spätschicht tritt die
Arbeit an Luca gabellini erst 22 und
schon Bäckermeister ist froh über seinen
späteren Arbeitsbeginn ja schon also
ganz gute Uhrzeit auf jeden Fall
und ich habe eigentlich ganz gut
ausgeschlafen dafür muss Luca sich von
der Nachtschicht erstmal was anhören
deswegen alles gut aber auch von der
ersten Schicht meist unterschätzt was
wir machen müssen ja zum Beispiel die
Backstube putzen am Ende des Tages alles
Gute wir schlagen uns nicht für mich ist
es eine große Erleichterung um 5 Uhr
anzufangen ich bin auch überzeugt davon
dass mehr Leute dann am Ende dem Beruf
auch von lernen werden wenn man spätere
Arbeitszeit hat so können Vater und Sohn
brücklmeier ihre Mitarbeiter halten und
neue gewinnen vor allem die jungen
wollen lieber tagsüber arbeiten früher
wäre das für Bäcker gar nicht möglich
gewesen aber jetzt mit alle möglichen
Computer
Kühlungen und mit allen möglichen
Steuerungen damit die Öfen ist es Gott
sei Dank möglich das heißt also ich muss
ja nicht das was auf Nacht oder
Nachmittag verkauft wird schon in der
Früh um drei Wochen sondern es reicht ja
wenn das dann am Vormittag gebacken ist
und die Früchte dass die Ware ist desto
besser lässt sich das verkaufen um halb
sieben öffnet der laden und dann geht
tatsächlich alles weg wie warme Semmeln
viele Leute holen vor der Arbeit frische
Brötchen fürs Frühstück
ganz andere Zeiten gelten bei Einhorn in
Berlin die Firma vertreibt vegane
Kondome und periodenprodukte 10 Uhr
vormittags und nur wenige der 25
Mitarbeitenden sind im Büro einen finden
wir aber doch Max schmil arbeitet an
einem fairtrade-projekt
ich bin schon regelmäßig im Büro weil
ich auch diesen Austausch gerne habe und
halt auch viele Projekte habe die
mehrere Abteilungen betreffen aber es
ist ja niemand da zum Austauschen zu den
zu dem vereinbarten Terminen tauchen die
Leute dann schon meistens auf in der
Logistikabteilung werden heute Pakete
gepackt das geht nicht von zu Hause aus
ich stellt einen Jahresvorrat zusammen
49 Kondome in lustigen Chipstüten vor
neun Monaten ist die 34-Jährige
logistikerin hierher gewechselt weil sie
anders arbeiten wollte raus aus starren
Strukturen denn zur Einhorn gekommen
weil ich weiß dass ich hier Freiheiten
habe also dass ich genau das Arbeiten
kann was ich gerne möchte weiß aber auch
dass das eine höhere Herausforderung ist
weil ich mich selber organisieren muss
ich genieße es aber dass ich mich voll
einbringen kann also dass wir alle auf
einer Ebene stehen und gemeinsam
Entscheidungen treffen das motiviert
mich sehr stark keine Chefs mehr das
heißt auch Chefinnen Aufgaben werden
hier von den Mitarbeitern erledigt und
niemand muss zur Arbeit kommen dafür
gibt es sogenannte null-bocktage ich
habe bis jetzt nicht wirklich null
bocktage gebraucht
weil ich einfach die Möglichkeit habe
frei zu arbeiten wie ich das für
notwendig erachte also es heißt ich
arbeite nicht jeden Tag von 9 bis 18 Uhr
und lass den Stift fallen sondern ich
mache wie was gemacht werden muss und
habe dadurch Zeit mich auch zu erholen
oder mal was im Haushalt zu machen und
dadurch erübrigt sich dieser Null
bocktag und so sieht das aus wenn alle
auch Chefinnen sind zusammen mit ihrer
Kollegin Linda bespricht Jenny eine
Entscheidungsvorlage die dann wieder ins
Team zurück gespielt wird seit sieben
Jahren arbeitet Linda schon hier und hat
erst 5:0 bocktage genommen und auch
nicht mehr als 30 Tage Urlaub was mich
zufrieden hier macht ist dass ich echt
das Gefühl habe ich darf und ich kann
mich dahin entwickeln wo ich mich hin
entwickeln möchte und wenn ich merke das
Thema finde ich gerade ultra spannend
und es passt zum Unternehmen natürlich
dann ist es voll die Option da weiter
reinzugehen und das macht mich schon
ziemlich glücklich sehr Verantwortung
abgibt bekommt auch etwas zurück im Fall
von Einhorn motivierte Mitarbeiter und
schwarze Zahlen
dieses unternehmerische Denken das
versuchen wir schon eigentlich in jedem
einzelnen reinzubringen und das ist gut
von Umsatz und wir haben natürlich jetzt
auch gemerkt dass die ganzen Freiheiten
und die wir gegeben haben in der
Vergangenheit dass sie sich nicht
negativ auf den Umsatz ausgewirkt haben
wir haben eine 32 Stunden Woche wir
haben unlimitierten Urlaub wir haben
arbeite waren und wo du willst und wir
sind trotzdem in profitabels Unternehmen
dass er seit acht Jahren da ist also das
funktioniert
inzwischen ist das auch wissenschaftlich
belegt eine Studie im Großbritannien hat
gezeigt dass nicht nur Arbeitnehmer mit
einer vier Tage Woche glücklicher sind
sondern dass auch die große Mehrheit der
beteiligten Unternehmen daran festhalten
will der Ökonom Marcel fratcher
beobachtet diese Veränderungen auf dem
Arbeitsmarkt Unternehmen stehen heute
mehr denn je im Wettbewerb um Köpfe um
Menschen und beschäftigte
und die Unternehmen die es nicht
schaffen diesen Wettbewerb zu bestehen
weil sie
ihren Beschäftigten nicht genug
Motivation geben nicht genug Freiheiten
nicht genug Mitbestimmung geben
Unternehmen die keine guten Löhne keine
guten Arbeitsbedingungen bieten die
werden ihre Beschäftigten eher früher
als später verlieren
für Unternehmen geht es darum dringend
benötigte Mitarbeiter zu finden und zu
binden doch funktioniert was ein kleiner
Handwerksbetrieb und ein cooles Startup
in Berlin machen auch für einen
Großkonzern wie die Münchner S-Bahn kurz
vor 8:30 Uhr am Morgen Tom und Martina
beginnen ihre Schicht bei der
Fahrkartenkontrolle
sie wird bestimmt selber unsere Uhrzeit
wollen wir anfangen wollen wir aufhören
über unsere schichtlänge wie lange wir
arbeiten wollen wir sind sogar soweit
dass wir sagen wann wir arbeiten an
welchen Tagen wir arbeiten ob wir lieber
am Wochenende arbeiten wann wir Ruhe
haben wir haben einen Dienstplan der ist
Blanco da ist nichts drauf und wir
schreiben den komplett selber
Schichtarbeit in Eigenregie das ist in
dieser Form einmalig bei der Deutschen
Bahn
für die Mitarbeiter ist das ein großer
Gewinn ich war vorher selbstständig über
40 Jahre im Friseurberuf gewesen und war
über 20 Jahre Friseurmeisterin es ist
ähnlich hier wie so eine Art
Selbstständigkeit und dieses flexible
das genieße hier und das liebe ich wie
zufrieden sie sind werden die
Mitarbeitenden im Betrieb regelmäßig
gefragt und tatsächlich ist sie
Zufriedenheit im Job gestiegen seit es
mehr Selbstverantwortung und
Mitbestimmung gibt unsere Mitarbeiter
wissen selbst am besten welche Linien am
auffälligsten sind die zu kontrollieren
sind sie wissen auch selber wann sie
irgendwie Urlaub haben und manche
Vertretung brauchen das müssen keine
Disponenten oder Führungskräfte für sie
entscheiden das sind alles erwachsenen
Menschen also behandeln wir sie auch so
als Chef muss man da auch loslassen
können Veränderung ist von allen gefragt
auf dem Weg in die neue Arbeitswelt
s-bahn-chef Heiko Büttner hat zum
Beispiel kein eigenes Büro mehr genau
wie alle anderen
das hat natürlich schon einen Moment
gedauert bis man sich daran gewöhnt hat
aber ich finde es klasse so viel mehr
Kommunikation passiert sozusagen viel
auf dem Flur nebenbei mal über den Tisch
also wenn man was hat dann einfach
rüberrufen und es ist irgendwie nahbar
also es ist ein nicht der Chef Chef also
es ist schon Chef aber irgendwo auf
meinen Kollege
der ist bei München hat jetzt nicht per
se den Ruf dass wir der innovativste
Arbeitgeber sind so ehrlich muss man mit
sich selbst sein aber wenn dann die
Leute zu uns kommen wenn sie anfangen
hier zu arbeiten wenn sie spüren dass
man sich einbringen kann dass man
wertgeschätzt wird dass man auch seine
Meinung sagen kann und die auf Interesse
stößt das spricht sich rum im
Arbeitsmarkt so gewinnt die S-Bahn immer
wieder neue Mitarbeiter
für viele ist es ein Traumjob
blockführer Stefan Ruhl macht ihn seit
zehn Jahren früher hieß das viele
Nachtschichten
ich bin nicht unbedingt so derjenige der
gerne in der Nacht durch die Gegend
fährt und lieber in meinem eigenen Bett
schläft und dann muss ich diese
Schichten immer wegtauschen das sind
natürlich mit Arbeit verbunden dann weiß
man ein bisschen schwierig ist jemand
der die Nachtschicht machen möchte seit
vier Jahren gibt es das System der
wunschichten für die Lokführer und zu
90% werden die Wünsche im Dienstplan
auch erfüllt
und heute stelle ich natürlich meine
Wünsche da steht keine Nachtschicht drin
und so bekomme ich auch keine
Nachtschicht und brauche mir da keine
Sorgen darum zu machen
es geht also der Fahrplan kennt kein
Pardon und dennoch gibt es flexible
Arbeitszeiten bei der Bahn Bäcker müssen
nicht zwingend um 3 Uhr anfangen sondern
können auch tagsüber arbeiten und Chefs
entscheiden nicht mehr alles von oben
herab die Arbeitswelt verändert sich
massiv es ist eine Zeitenwende die viel
mehr Spielraum bringt für Arbeitnehmer
[Musik]